when you think about the average citizen
what is the path uh to educating them on
the actual asset on monetary history on
economics like how do you how far deep
down the rabbit hole do you think that
the average citizen has to go until the
light clicks and they say oh i get it
like this is something that i want this
is something that i need to use
well this you know pop this is the uh
the the always the big question you know
because bitcoin is
is is not something that
you can pick up over the weekend you
know you really have to think about it
for a while and and think deeply about
it you know for me what i always talk
about
first whenever i talk to people is the
the quality of bitcoin where it's
unconfiscatable uh so this is really
unique in his history uh we've never had
a as a species the opportunity to have
wealth that's un uh you know absolutely
uncomplicated
and that resonates that really you know
people like that idea and the folks here
who were unbanked right 70 of the
country
before bitcoin was unbanked now 70
percent of the country is relatively
banked as they all have now the chivo
wallet they have access to bitcoin so
that was a flip you know an incredible
change and people like that idea you
know i come up to people come up to me
all the time in the street and they pick
up their show me their phone and they go
i have twenty dollars you know like i'm
like wow that's [ __ ] awesome dude uh
yeah and they know that they nobody can
take that you know this is this is
theirs it's unconfiscatable and this is
they can't be inflated away it can't be
taken from the government uh it can't be
stolen it can't be extorted uh and this
is significant now the other thing is
that it's uncensorable so um this is
particularly key for remittances right
so money going back from fourth from el
salvador to the us uh this money can go
and nobody can stop it nobody can can
stop that transaction it's uncensorable
so those those two key points uh i think
get into it people you know they're that
gets them over the hump they're like
well you know that sounds good let me
try it let me download this let me get
let me get started
so there's a recent uh appearance by
michael saylor uh he went and he talked
with uh with bloomberg and he gave 10
steps that he believes will make bitcoin
a stronger asset i want to go through
each one of these 10 kind of get your
thoughts in terms of ones you agree with
ones you disagree with or ones that you
think that you can elaborate further on
uh the first one is that he says that
there's an absence of the no wash
trading rule uh which basically allows
people if bitcoin is purchased at 50 000
it drops in price you can basically sell
it buy it back you can book the loss uh
and then continue to hold the same
amount of bitcoin agree disagree good or
bad for bitcoin
yeah i'm glad you brought this up i
think this is really interesting because
michael sayler is at an interesting
point in his bitcoin experience right uh
he's now going through what anyone who's
been in this
space for like i've been in it for 11
years right started buying it at a
dollar i've been through three halvings
i've been through
four maybe five eighty percent
corrections and so michael is having his
first you know big
you know cream pie in the face uh of
volatility everyone experiences with
bitcoin at some point i think his basis
that microstrategy is 30
700 and of course they're down you know
on paper from that but um so this list
of things he came up with to try to
address what he's what he says and what
he thinks is uh could be improved upon
now the wash sale trading rule uh my i
would give that you know a a i'm fairly
ambivalent about that it's like yeah
that would be kind of nice but um i mean
he's trying to avoid this hyper trading
that's going on
uh people trading without any cost
whatsoever uh into kind of the fastest
moving uh you know i'll say [ __ ] coin i
don't know you know i mean altcoin uh
and there's a tremendous amount of
social media where you see hyping of
of a meme coin and so there's no penalty
for that mass of meme coiners out there
to just jump into a new one there's no
tax penalty et cetera so bringing in a
wash sale rule would would theoretically
put a buffer between that kind of uh
murmurations as i call it pomp you know
if you ever look
up in the sky you see starlings and the
flying and they're flying in these
fantastic
constellations of birds and they
seemingly just
can
can go with thousands of birds
simultaneously that's kind of like the
altcoin market and all these traders
they're hyping on social media and they
go from very rapidly from one to the
other and they're playing this
extraordinary game
and uh so that's theoretically what
would kind of put a bumper uh on that
activity
so i guess i guess it's okay but but
you're you know you're opening the door
to regulation
so that's where i would say put a
caution light there
the next point that he made was that
there's 520 unregistered and unregulated
crypto exchanges uh that offer 20x
leverage and his point was that this
often leads to unprotected investors
which can lead to massive losses agree
disagree and good or bad for bitcoin
well you know again michael is somewhat
of a newbie uh you know it wasn't too
long ago when over there bit max you can
get a hundred x leverage so uh 20x
leverage is moving toward a more sane
environment than 100x but um i mean
obviously
again um that kind of leverage is not
consistent with
the um
kind of the guardrails that should be in
place for the average retail in investor
uh and so having access to that it's
almost guaranteed you're gonna get
wrecked um it really turns platforms
like coinbase and others that they
become more like casinos i've called
them casinos before unlicensed casinos
uh and so it has that element to it
where you're you're you're really you
know you're putting up a penny and
you're gambling on 100 on the 20x or 30x
and as you know that type of trading is
is almost guaranteed a loser uh so
i mean he's right
uh in terms of um of that kind of um
existence of of uh
you know as a casino operations going on
uh he's correct again it opens the door
toward regulators so that's that would
be the downside
so the next point that he made uh was
this idea that there's 19 000
cryptocurrencies being
cross-collateralized and associated with
bitcoin uh and that currently holds
bitcoin back by comparing it to badly
managed unregistered securities uh i'm
scared to ask you but agree or disagree
good or bad for bitcoin
well this is enough this is a this is an
interesting point so you know we've been
in this for a while and that these
points are not new uh you know michael's
just discovering them because you know
because this is the learning curve
people have but um
you know
the everything that's not bitcoin as
i've said on your show before
would come under the heading of either
relatively or absolutely
centralized versus bitcoin which is
uniquely
decentralized additionally a case can be
made applying the howie test then
everything that's not bitcoin would be
an unregistered security right so and um
it also
brings about the question about senator
lomas uh in her bill that she's trying
to get through congress uh talking about
applying some regulations to
quote-unquote crypto and she does things
like she equates ethereum and bitcoin
she calls them both commodities which i
think is
false i mean you can make a case that
bitcoin is a commodity like gold but
clearly ethereum is an unregistered
security without
without any doubt whatsoever so gary
gensler over at the sec it kind of
pushed back against all this and said
hey lady you know stay in your lane uh
you don't know you're talking about
which i think is the correct correct
response but um when the
cross-collateralization
issue that he's getting at is really
really the crisis du jour i would say uh
because of what we saw with terra luna
and all these other
d5 coins that they're manufacturing that
yield
you know pomp from
kind of cross-collateralizing and
putting money to work into other defy
coins and these other default coins are
generating returns like by creating
coins out of thin air
i mean by definition that's a ponzi
scheme so a lot of that defy return is
just cross-collateralizing into
new situations that are creating coins
out of thin air and rewarding early uh
you know coin rewards et cetera again
unregistered securities uh so you that
that's definitely an issue
and here i think that
this is definitely a regulatory issue
where this definitely would require
regulatory
um
kind of um
enforcement and and you see these things
for example uh
uh
the in with luna uh these guys are are
definitely getting into big trouble i i
believe they're completely prevented
from leaving
south korea they're being held by the
police so uh you know this is this is
definitely an issue so i think with that
you know he he understands that this is
what what's
what's what's keeping the lead on
bitcoin at the moment is you've got
hundreds of billions of dollars you've
got people like sam bankman freight over
at ftx who's become a king maker by
creating these enormous uh kind of
cross-collateralized market making
unregis unregulated
situations where price discovery can't
take place you know this is something
that people talked about a couple years
ago they said will bitcoin experience
the same problems gold has because
there's no good price discovery in gold
because of all the derivatives
and so wall street can of can really
decide what the price of gold should be
not the market and what sailor's
pointing out is we're seeing this now in
bitcoin you've got derivatives or d phi
that are
making creating price discovery for
bitcoin uh and it's and it's it's it's
blocking it from from a more natural
price discovery from taking place so
i think he's got an excellent point
there and this is definitely under the
wheelhouse of the sec they're they're
definitely should be enforcing in this
case and and they're being lacks
and it's unclear why
the sec is is being lacked
so his next point was connected to this
which is this idea of these wildcat
banks the ability for uh centralized
platforms or uh decentralized and name
uh platforms to actually offer
unsustainable yields uh and kind of
gamify uh or or celebrate a lot of these
what uh what is your thoughts there good
or bad uh for bitcoin and do you agree
or not
well it's like a tag on to the to the
previous point right it's just that he's
just emphasizing the same point you've
got these what he called wildcat banks
um these big platforms and they're
interrupting price discovery and they're
doing so in a way that's manipulative
and fraudulent and it's the perfect
opportunity for the for the sec to step
in and enforce the rules
and so when you start to think about his
next point he listed ignorance and fear
of the asset class as a lack of
technical know-how still terrifies many
as does media coverage telling of the
many supposed deaths of bitcoin kind of
the the sentiment the conversation the
lack of information being a problem what
is your thoughts there agree or disagree
and uh good or bad for bitcoin
well the adoption is definitely tied to
understanding bitcoin and we know that
the more you learn about bitcoin the
more of a maximalist you become
uh nobody who
learns
about bitcoin fails to become a
maximalist only people who really don't
take the time to learn about it are left
in the camp of a no coiner or a skeptic
but on this point i think what he's
missing is the global nature of bitcoin
so in the us
which has the u.s dollar and it has
a much different culture and the
financial markets are in a much
different place
this is a bigger problem to get through
to people who are bombarded with um
so many things happening uh in the
financial space and the way that that's
changing
you know i look at how for example
gambling has become legalized with
platforms um
now that that we didn't really have even
a few years ago but if you look around
the world places like el salvador the
global south place in africa
the the need for bitcoin is so great
that the learning curve is very fast
they just get it there's a need for it
and that's where you're going to see the
growth pop you know bitcoin is really
very much going to be the global south
making a move on the global north you're
going to see uh the changing of the
guard uh the central banks the federal
reserve bank and the bank of england uh
european central bank are going to be
usurped they're going to be overtaken by
this bitcoin revolution and it's going
to come from these other countries it's
not going to be led by
the united states so i would suggest to
michael saylor that he take his message
to overseas you know get take your yacht
and sail to uh countries uh that where
bitcoin is adopted and the learning
curve is rapid because there's a real
need for it you know
throw america under the bus for now
because they're just mired in too much
other stuff these other countries
however
it's where it's happening faster because
the need is clear and and the asset is
performing brilliantly for
you know these millions of people and
soon to be a billion people and more
he made the point that we don't have a
real stable coin yet because there isn't
one that is fully regulated and approved
agree or disagree and good or bad for
bitcoin
all right this i totally disagree with
michael saylon
because when you're talking about a
regulated stable coin you're talking
about a cbdc a central bank digital
currency you're talking about usdc the
circle coin you're talking about a fed
coin you're talking about a surveillance
coin and you're you're removing
one of the best aspects of bitcoin
in that the on-ramp would be outside of
the banking system right bitcoin exists
outside of the banking system
and it's
so when you have a regulated stable coin
you're creating a regulated on-ramp to
bitcoin and defeating the purpose of
bitcoin so that and that and this when
this piece that michael saylor mentions
i i i completely disagree and i think it
goes against the ethos of bitcoin this
is something that he and i have talked
about before i i'm 180 degrees in
opposition of this idea so let me ask a
clarifying question here which is uh
regulated stable coin is different than
stable coin is your thought process that
there will be stable coins and people
will use them but they just won't be the
central bank digital currencies or like
how do you think this plays out uh do
you think these stable coins end up all
failing and nobody adopts them uh and
bitcoin is kind of the last remaining
one
well tether is working great you know
it's the biggest one out there and um it
they just added the the mexican peso and
they added the british pound they have
the us dollar i believe they have the
euro
and um it's it works fine and uh it
works for the unbanked so the tether
model is fine and uh it will resist
being encroached upon by nefarious
regulators
and so when you think about that it's
really just the the regulated component
versus more of a free market stablecoin
is really where the difference in maybe
you and sailor's opinion
yes
i would say that's correct yeah it um it
feels like stable coins are going to be
a thing but i think the nuance of free
market versus regulated is up for debate
right so that makes a ton of sense